uh the real the real issue here that's I
guess most interesting is that we're
we're seeing a number of a number of
people whose reputations and knowledge
base and skills uh are significant
uh who have chosen to uh uh to join the
uh
the the
people who feel that the growth and
Research into into
the uh as generative AI a large language
Model A is the iei stuff really needs to
be slowed and controlled and done by
quote experts end of quote whereas uh
some other people and I'm in that
category sort of think that that's uh
that was it would have been an
interesting uh Choice quite a while ago
but right now the genie is out of the
bottle and it's unlikely that we can put
it back in
and that in fact the large language
model AI is going to become a standard
uh tool of everybody particularly people
trying to change the world
um perhaps last week or the week before
and so that we really sort of need to
figure out what how we feel about it
it's quite clear that the lane they're
not a perfect mechanism at this point it
works fairly well but not not great
and yet uh it's good enough so that many
things look look very very good
um and it can be used to to accomplish
things and it is self-improving in the
sense that as experience grows and it
gets incorporated into the the the data
that's used to generate the
uh the processes the um
the new this newly discovered things yet
Incorporated in amongst the older things
and things get better and better
[Music]
um
so I think that's that's going to be a
big problem
and I'm curious as to what's going on
there seems to be a strong bias
uh throughout the uh uh the uh people
who are experimenting with this that
this is dangerous technology and that
you need to wear uh protective clothing
and so forth and you uh when you work on
uh on the the uh a large language model
AIS
um I'm not certain I believe that but
certainly many people many people behave
that way
everybody's getting in the ACT yeah
and lots of specialized systems are
being put together uh there are people
building legal systems there'd be people
building uh
dating systems
and uh
almost everything everything that you
can do uh in terms of interacting with
humans is uh seems to have a somebody
working on a variant of of the chat jpt
which is targeted to that particular
space
um
I'm gonna be a mob scene do you think so
maybe
because everybody and their brothers
into it whether they know what they're
doing or not
[Music]
well okay but what does it mean to know
what you're doing
correct that's true
yeah so I read hinton's uh interview or
pieces of it and one thing that struck
me was he's assuming
um linear if he's extrapolating the
rapid rate of improvement that we've
seen over the last couple of years
and we've seen this before we saw this
with the self-driving cars they improved
dramatically very quickly and then all
of a sudden plateaued and I'm wondering
if that's something that's likely to
happen here or not
well I don't know
um
I mean there there are lots of examples
um where uh the Moors log like like
things of uh have
have uh
just continued on for a long time
I mean it took it took uh uh almost 50
years before it was Moore's Law it came
uh
obsolete
and it wasn't repealed it was just
modified
true but there are plenty of things that
that have
saturated and slowed down the
performance dramatically and so uh the
question is which one is these
um a lot of it
um is uh data Limited they accelerate
very fast until they've consumed all the
data
and then
they can't improve more without a lot
more data and so that seems to be a
limiting factor in these learning
systems at least
um yeah
but do we do we know that the systems
that people are using
like gpt4 our really learning systems or
are they something else
because at least my understanding of how
it works is basically it's uh it it's
really a uh a short short-term somatic
semiotic predictor it looks it has a
language it's it that he's using and it
predicts the next thing in some uh some
sense by some mechanism and that gives
it another piece of information that it
builds on that so it's a basically a
a projection into some sort of space of
probabilistic space of Futures and one
of them is selected by some mechanism
and that mechanism is considered the
Opera yeah there was an interesting
example in the New York Times where they
showed how the response evolved over the
two seconds you have to wait to get it
from just random characters to utter
gibberish to semi-sensible to the final
results but again it's it's based it
improves by getting more data to improve
its statistics and if when it runs out
of data doesn't that limit its
Improvement
um I don't know
that was my question so I was hoping
anybody out there who would like to
comment on that right now I don't know
yeah hello hello yeah I'm just setting
up uh I think this question was also
brought up in the video that uh then you
shared before it is
colloquial
so uh the point is that uh on top on
point of data is uh
that there is a chance to try to turn
out some data due to the complexity of
the system that can generate its own
data
so
um and since also there are new features
appearing which also I found I think
mentioned in the video if I remember
correctly that it start to transcribe
information from audio
um means so mediums like radio or maybe
some podcasts YouTube
is a book source so
this one as well and uh yeah so it's
also worth I think uh definitely
starting how this process go but again
due to the Black Box
um going on uh in the system it can be a
little complicated or quite complicated
to do that
yeah
I think that's that's exactly true
first of all we we don't know there
might be much larger collections of data
that may be available either immediately
or shortly
there's I mean imagine translating all
of the YouTube uh videos just you know
converting them into uh text and feeding
it in you know there may be a lot of
sources like that second thing is we
don't really know how much there already
is in there because we're we're just
beginning to discover the mind the
actionable insights that are available
in the databases that they currently
have and uh related point to that is
that as the models get bigger you know
as they throw more computing power at it
you get a more fine-grained detail of uh
what they can do uh and what you know
what they can express and so we we just
you know we may be able to increase
computing power and get a lot more out
of these systems than than where I just
you know we may just be scratching the
surface today you know I was just
reading a bunch of stuff today it's some
of it's pretty disturbing about you know
what kinds of things you can persuade
these systems to do so they're putting
out tools rules that have the
possibility that they could do some very
bad things and people can use them for
some very bad things we just don't know
yet you know that that's in there and
and that it's capable in ways that they
can you know customize persuasion and
change the way advertising is done and
you know pollute our Public Square you
know these are all issues that I think
are very real but uh I don't know if
it's we're if it's going to be
asymptotic at some point but it's not at
all clear that we're anywhere near that
do you think you think that the
output of the uh various uh systems that
people build will get Incorporated in
the inputs and used be used to build the
models
um well I don't know where I read that
but I just saw something that basically
since it learns the language these
systems can generate language and then
you can feed that back in and that does
in fact improve their performance now
that's got to be asymptotic at some
point but uh it's just another technique
for accelerating you know what what kind
of value get out of these enormous
Collections and sort of humanities
knowledge
um
do you think that that that the
structure that we have which is
basically a sort of forward predictive
uh uh probabilistic one where we select
out a path through some very complicated
probabilistic hyperspace uh by some
technique and that that remains to be uh
verified of course but is that is that
going to be is that a is that a hint as
to how Consciousness works
if you're asking me I haven't got a clue
the whole thing you know like you guys
most of you guys I've been looking at
this step for 50 years and
I never I can't believe this it's
happening I'm actually kind of in a way
I'm I'm grateful that I lived to see
this you know this is a real game
changer
uh and I don't think we can minimize
that not to say it's not going to have
limitations you know it's not the uh you
know the uh
super intelligent uh thing that's going
to take over the Earth but
um you know I I have no idea the idea
that predicting the next word can lead
or the next token can lead to the stuff
that we're seeing is just to me it's
inexplicable you know it's like aliens
landed and they're playing a joke on us
in his
expressing themselves through this
mechanism
I have no idea where this goes you know
I understand that that's exactly my
feeling yeah you know if if people like
us think that you know we're just not
going to know the answer for for a while
and you know I I
you know it's hard enough to describe it
to people what's going on and you know
like I'm getting asked I'm sure you
folks are too you know everybody from uh
my mother who's still around amazingly
enough to to you know people writing to
me just saying what's this going to mean
and uh I I I don't know I'm having
trouble thinking now
another interesting feature that you
know I was just working on a piece of
software where I have to have a you know
run a bunch of test cases and then test
cases fail and I try to improve the
software so it passes more test cases it
seems to me that you know the ability
for uh systems like this to run software
really kind of is remarkable because not
only can they potentially improve the
underlying software but they could
potentially generate more test cases
which could then you know improve the
software more which you know so the
ability of generating new test cases and
also if you look at simulation you know
like at some point you're going to be
able to simulate you know molecules and
chemistry and all sorts of things and
sort of you know aggregate systems now
there may be a scalability issue uh but
I think you know the ability of the
systems to generate more new test cases
for themselves uh it's pretty clear that
that could happen in software and I
expect it could happen in other domains
as well
yeah I just I just attended the Stanford
security day and one of the talks was
using uh the co-pilot for writing
helping you write code and the problem
was that the code that co-pilot
recommended was far less secure than the
code that people who didn't use copilot
ended up writing and in fact one example
was co-pilot recommended this block of
code and in the comments it said for
educational purposes only do not use
um and so we still have some risks there
in terms of using these things as uh as
uh code writers for us although I'm very
bad at writing tests and I'd love to get
somebody to help me write tests so that
might be safer than having it generate
the code well it's a good thing that
human programmers never like mindlessly
cut and paste from stack Overflow or
from other pieces of Code by the way I
haven't example from stack Overflow that
says you should use the same password
and if highly upvoted it's got 170
upvotes it says you should use the same
password at google.com and
google.evil.com so there's
okay
okay uh I'd say yeah uh I just I just
wanted to respond to it about how the
co-pilot recommended this in code that
was less secure than what they ended up
going through but if you if you're a
co-pilots just another stream of like
information
it's not supposed to it's it wouldn't
necessarily always like as a human would
not always like the perfect piece of
code that would solve the problems in
the best way possible so it's kind of
like you have to look at it with lots of
multiple people multiple co-pilots take
a look at the same block of code and
evaluated they say this one is more
Superior than that one and then make a
decision as the same way we write code
these days like whenever I write before
I need at least with other two or three
other people at the company to review it
and kind of get me back some feedback
before we can push it to production so
there are levels of um
right well you know they they um they uh
big survey that the programmers and the
programmers who use copilot thought they
were generating more secure code than
the programmers who were not using
copilot which is is a danger too but yes
you know code reviews are critical if
anybody wants to review my code please
do but one rule is you're not allowed to
laugh at it but
um anyway I thought that was an
interesting point and and the the
conclusion was that co-pilot lacked
context
so in particular in file access it it
couldn't understand
when the context said that it was okay
to open any file and when the request
was coming from an untrusted source and
that meant that uh it couldn't provide
the kind of security guarantees that a
programmer who knows the context could
and that was the conclusion of the talk
um
well you know I haven't had a chance
over the years to look at large pieces
of uh code in places like the internet
and
um I'm not so sure that we are not
running uh code that's uh more of the
a demonstration and educational use in
production uh than we uh perhaps ought
to be even today
um a lot of a lot of early code exists
and is used no matter
what the security review might say
unfortunately yeah yeah
but there was another article
um in the again in the New York Times
about how it's not going to replace
people doing the work but it will do the
boring parts of their jobs for them
uh treating this as a an overall benefit
at least in that aspect not not putting
people out of work but letting them
focus on the hard problems rather than
the drug dealer I don't know to what
extent people agree with that
does anyone agree
because I I would I would have a hard
put to say what what part of Any Given
job is the boring part
you know if I could yeah
um I think I think that's that's the way
it was described is putting lipstick on
the pig you hear this every time it's an
advanced in automation oh no we're not
putting people out of work we're just
making them more productive we're only
automating the routine or the the bad
parts no you're you're automating
whatever it is that's going to make a
higher degree of productivity so you can
do more with less and if that's
automating the exciting parts and you're
stuck you know and like the workers in
an Amazon Factory now they just stick
stuff in boxes because that's the only
part that can't be automated uh that
that's the way that's going to go down
the idea that this isn't going to affect
the labor is silly it's it's going to
have dramatic impacts on labor and I
don't think that's necessarily bad I
think this is very common there's been
wave after wave of this kind of stuff
and it's going to transform most jobs as
far as I can see but it's also going to
eliminate a lot of jobs and create a
whole bunch of different jobs as well
yep I agree with that yeah
foreign
awful lot of jobs
um and it's probably going to eliminate
jobs in sectors that have been fairly
protected in uh in in uh in past years
uh if you noticed in the uh the current
uh problem with television and movie
writers and uh the uh producing agencies
uh they want to have protection against
the uh scripts written by uh by Bots
by the way one of the most amazing
things I saw in one of these videos was
the the sick the four words from
Hemingway
and the stories that they that the the
AI wrote uh baby shoes never worn and it
wrote this very touching story
um that to me blows me away
I'd watch that
yeah
so we may get actual better programming
from the box that generate Netflix
programs is what you're saying yeah some
of them are pretty bad
I I watch them almost anything with
space and I'm currently watching a very
bad one
is there a good one oh yeah there have
been a few good ones but uh but mostly
mostly they're Dreadful but I can do the
crossword puzzle while I'm watching okay
which one is that I don't know right I
have to think right now which which one
uh um
oh uh Sisyphus I just started
um it sounds interesting but it's got
these crazy plot holes in episode one
for what it's worth you know there's
there's a is a show which is very
directly relevant to the conversation
here that just came out called Mrs Davis
yes the name itself is supposed to be
kind of off-putting or it's it's it
could have been so much better it is
driving me crazy that is as insane as it
is
I mean they're not really addressing
they're showing the problems of this
overarching AI without ever exploring
the social effects of it and the the the
the storyline is pretty much orthogonal
to the AI I don't know it's uh it's
irritating me I'm five episodes in but
well it's because it wasn't written by
an AI who knows about what it's like
today
there you go uh I actually been um
previously trying to use chat TPT to
actually study the chat TPT so including
its social effects and asking about if
it can offer me material is pretty good
it does offer material how to provide
the safety regulation so at least it
pointed correctly to the literature that
can uh for example tell more about
ethical Concepts and how to use those in
practice so it was quite interesting and
there is General
um
and I remember who actually wrote it
exactly
um but I think it was also
in a book of kokilberg who wrote a book
on ethics is that you can use the tools
uh against the system who made those
tools in order to fight them but it's
also requires certain structure so that
for example like a regulations that um
you can use these tools to fight back
so I think this may be else yes because
this is jet CPT is also made like an
assistant
so that's one of the biggest risks I
think uh to the job that it may pause
it's the job of assistance yeah because
it does do a good job in that in some
sense so of course it depends on the
type of assistance uh people require so
I think it is quite interesting to use
it when studying itself so it won't
reveal information uh how it was made
like an Etc so more not public but it
does help to find information how to
actually work on these issues I just saw
an example where they asked it and it
cited four books to explain how it works
and none of those books actually exist
I saw I saw a cited version where that
was a paper instead and they cited three
four different things and two of the
papers didn't exist so the the AI wrote
One
okay that's interesting it's um for me
it was so that some links didn't work
but when it comes to the official
sources like IEEE Institute and the
other so like from European commission
those files existed just the links that
it provided I don't know why but those
doesn't just work so you have to
research it the piece of information for
example it provides you
make Concepts it's named correctly at
least from the academic literature yeah
I was wondering this is these things are
trained on everything that's on the
internet I I was wondering what would
happen if we find it on more or less
vetted sources published books
um
newspapers and that that actually
published Errata when they make a
mistake uh scientific journals and left
out uh things from unvetted sources like
Twitter and Facebook posts and whatnot I
wondered if that would make a difference
at least in terms of the hallucination
problem
uh that's an interesting question
um
so uh this is sort of like uh saying you
don't want to uh you don't want to teach
history in the public schools because
it's uh sometimes disturbing no it means
I don't want to learn history in the
public schools from all my neighbors I
want to learn it from historians
okay of all stripes
but I want vetted I want vetted sources
I want people who if they make a mistake
correct are willing to admit it and will
correct it
we don't get that in in real life no but
we do get it in in newspapers they
always have Corrections we get it in
textbooks with Errata sections we get in
review journals we get in review
journals even though the students appear
there is an effort to be correct
whereas on the general internet there's
often an incentive not to be and so I'm
just wondering if what would happen if
we built something that was trained on
vetted sources
um
I I think you're right the issue here is
is uh curation right and I think that
what's going to happen is it's expensive
to curate stuff and people are going to
develop curated databases and they're
gonna you know give you access to it but
it's going to cost money uh the quality
of the stuff you get it's like the whole
reason we had Bloomberg terminals as you
probably know was they had access to all
of the accurate financial information
that other people uh you know were just
you know my cousin says I should buy IBM
you know it was not the level of uh
curation that they wanted so right now
this is just you know they just throw
everything in there it's a kitchen sink
but I think that uh my guess is a whole
ecosystem of uh people to mine curate
data to stick into these systems is
going to be very important for the same
reason that you know I read the New York
Times and I don't read I don't know
barely Beast or something maybe that's a
bad example but but my question but then
the question is is there enough
content to to reach the you know the
level you need to make it useful
I don't know it's a good question so
it's a difficult question Alan I don't
see how you uh you can do that except
experimentally
again and it's as he said it's expensive
but you know co-pilot costs like 10
bucks a month now and
um I'm sure that
somebody who spends the money to curate
could find a business model to recover
that yeah
the other question is uh you know the
predictors all seem to be
um
seem to be sort of next to symbol
and maybe you should be predicting two
symbols or four symbols or three symbols
or something I had
and that would give a slightly larger
range of uh of possibilities and might
converge more quickly
or it might take lots longer to converge
or never converge at all
yeah that's that's the concern because
it's a the wide branching tree
right
okay
I don't know I think I'm going to have
to write one
but then then I have to find a way to
get my to my data in that's that's of
course
the the critical thing
[Music]
so what do you think is going to happen
here that I mean
um
if these
is this technology gets applied very
broadly across our our society
which is I'd say
probability one
um
to what extent are we dependent on
technology well I mean there are
enormous benefits like I read that it it
solves all the folding problem of all
the proteins in the human body in a
matter of a couple of months where it
would take a PhD thesis per protein
um
without it which is which is pretty
remarkable so they're clearly benefits
here but the risks you know there's uh
if the fake videos and fake pictures the
pope and the fluffy jacket that fooled a
lot of people
um it's going to make it that you won't
be able to trust Your Lying Eyes anymore
um that's that's a real risk
or maybe it maybe it's a benefit we'll
we'll learn to be more more cautious
about what we what we believe from what
we read and see because this this fake
stuff will be so persistent
Gloria well maybe or you'll end up with
something like we had with the covet
virus where there was a whole industry
created on being anti-covered virus and
anti-vaccine and uh
companies of substantial size with the
substantial uh video production skills
we're producing uh documentaries which
were sold over YouTube or places like
that uh which were pretty nice fiction
yeah I think that this concern in terms
that it may teach us not to believe so I
think we already experienced something
like that and later it may just get
worse in the sense that you cannot
believe anything what you see or what
you hear which can be quite problematic
because human is actually made on trust
We Trust others that they will not
attack us we trust others to actually
build something so this is how Society
is built it's built on trust initially
so in some sense you have to turn your
back to others and let them cover it for
you so that you can do your thing
because if we would just constantly try
to protect ourselves we wouldn't
actually make it to Society at all we're
not talking even the level as it is now
and of course it is about how to enjoy
the good things and try to minimize the
bad
the side effects that it has and which
are can be quite severe and I think that
one way is the certification that I
think I previously talked about so then
it would limit the access so again since
this powerful technology
it would just
um
help uh to minimize who has access to
this in sense that it may be available
public but not to the full capacity
because again it can be weaponized it
can be used for many things and it's
also important to actually introduce
certain education for General users
how to make decisions with such things
how to receive information from such
tools because now we're introducing
digital literacy in school but since the
technology pace is quite fast it's also
I think important to include AI tools as
well so
um that would be definitely important at
least I think it's highly important to
teach kids because we can all right okay
we can kind of manage it sometimes but
when it comes to more vulnerable Minds
there is some definite explanation and
lessons should be given so again
certification would also not only
establish who can kind of use the
technology or who has a right to do to
do that but also when you're a
certificate that means you pass through
a certain training
it means that you know or learned about
this technology and it's also good to
include the ethical
um and also
other type of social consequences that
it may bring
so for example even those teams of
ethics and society that even where in
Microsoft
so there was this article that thought
that they actually helped to understand
how the consequence because sometimes we
just cannot see what can happen it
requires explanation examples uh and
other types of work to actually give uh
this kind of view because
yes one thing when you start it or when
you kind of interacted with this before
and you understand this but the other
thing is when you never actually faced
this before so you may have some ideas
but never explored or never get got the
opportunity to do that so this is also
important and I think the certain
shifting power so from certain companies
that own the technology because now
there is this big race
going on so who will basically dominate
in this area
there's this technology so if only one
company or two companies in the world
control AI basically
what it mean also for us so because
again this powerful technology it also
studies human so it may persuade right
it may influence uh it may do many other
things uh that actually uh in this uh
human computer interaction that can
influence opinion or ideas
so you know so subtle it may not even be
so much pointed at at first or even
considered to be as breaking some law or
human rights because some of this
influences are so subtle that it only
later comes so clear that what was
happening and it may take quite a while
which is problematic so
yes so I think we we do have a model in
the handling of biological systems where
we have the level one for things that
are if they escape the lab it's not
terrible and level four we have a
pandemic if it does
and I wonder if that's a model that we
can use to regulate these systems uh yes
I think it's very interesting and before
um I thought also looking in this
direction because generally this type of
things are already
considered as having big social impact
so yes again if Corona gets out it has
not only like impact on Health on social
as well and many of us experienced it
before it wasn't so clear
so but now we know that it's lockdown
has effects on mentality we can't just
put our bodies uh in apartment or in a
house in some space
and stay there
why not like logically why not like you
could just stay make some calls to your
close one it also has this subtle
influences that influence human not our
logic we not only logical creatures so
we're not consist purely of syntax
and I think it also getting into the
system this understanding of human
nature and again like you mentioned this
um level four level one I think it's
classifications would be important also
classification and the fields is
important I think because different AI
in different disciplines affect
disciplines differently so one thing
when it's like in the medicine another
thing when it's on social media and Etc
so I think it's important and as I will
start staying regarding um
crisper right so we know it may affect
human and following Generations
so there are strict tribulations and
safety procedures how actually use it so
there is rigorous testing
before it gets out or even used uh for
something
so in that sense yes it is a good like a
blueprint but there is of course some
adjustments uh required
my friends written a science fiction
book uh actually a series and one of the
key Parts is that crispr has escaped and
has become available to terrorists so
and that would be a risk for trying to
limit the AI this way too so this would
be a big risk because okay one thing you
affect one generation
okay but you follow uh you don't
influence all other Generations
so would you prohibit people don't have
any children those who are affected if
it's a huge for example I don't know
piece of population of certain country
or even worldwide how then it's
approached because again this is
prohibited for a reason because one yes
you may know approximately or you may be
sure that this piece of um DNA response
for this element but it may also respond
for something else
and then it can be a problem yeah you
know like there was uh deeming uh crispr
implemented for twins uh for I think HIV
protection because one of their parents
had HIV so that they would be safe yes
you know now but there's definitely
prison time involved yeah but uh I'm not
sure uh how long and whether it's
actually how did they later approach
this situation but it was definitely a
shock that this technology was used
for Gene editing because their children
of these children will also have this so
it's gonna stay there
I just uh like you started talking I got
an idea that or I wanted to add that um
same can be this AI because this soil
influences on our nature human nature
can also be passed down so like people
from uh like our parents right they had
their ideas in them so which they passed
down whether they accept them or not
they still influence same can be here
like social media those people who grew
up with it will have certain ideas that
will be passed down how maybe the mind
the ideas
uh covered against Society they also
will be passed down so it all influences
maybe not directly biological but it
does
yeah I just wanted to go back to was
saying about how
um this technology kind of uh well how
you were saying it kind of reminded me
of like how we're treating like nuclear
technology at this time the know-how of
how to make nuclear weapons or how to do
anything when it comes to that field is
heavily guarded and has become something
that you can only you know study at
certain places they only give the
information to once you reach certain
clearance or security level would you
think that would like um Carry On for AI
because if anyone is able to create a
large language model and be able to
scrape the internet for data and create
these models that are capable of
um I don't know doing whatever you want
there is no way to kind of limit to have
certifications or have some sort of uh I
don't know blocks in order to in our
words protect Society from its effects
they can be deployed anywhere because
we're so interconnected with the
internet so how with how that work would
you think there would be a kind of like
restriction on the studying of uh large
language models and generated AI or do
you think that's not necessary in order
to keep you know to keep in order to
introduce uh certifications and
introduce limits on how it's allowed to
be used when it's allowed to be used and
what kind of models can be made I don't
think it's possible to control studying
it that's for sure but I'll answer the
rest of the questions
I hope somebody can also talk because I
think I talk too much on this
no you're very you're very you're very
clear about them uh you're you're what
you say it and uh we appreciate it
enormously and you're the only
professional on the topic here too so
I'm a professional just to read a lot
and start to work is this but maybe I'm
getting there okay so like also this
point was individual of Ruskin and
Harris from Center for human technology
that uh Dennis shared so there was this
a very interesting idea uh that nukes
cannot make stronger nukes but AI can
make stronger AI so it can actually
enhance enhance itself
plus
um nukes are dependent on certain
material that certain countries can get
AI doesn't
so you can make it uh you don't you need
just enough computing power and um
like purchase all the things and also
depends on the how strong you want to
make it uh how you want to train it so
to what extent uh it will be
unsupervised because that also depends
computation and uh so it could be used
in that sense but it's still different
case that's what's important to
understand because there is still there
is some limits by countries But Here
There Are No Limits it's like a
worldwide so you can't like there is
certain ways to of course regulate that
there are ideas and there is an action
becoming clearer but it just still uh
there it is good idea to look into this
field as well to learn from it yet it
still requires understanding that it's
something else so we have not really
faced this type of ubiquitous technology
before I think
so then it would be possible or would
not be possible to kind of limits and
certify certain people to make certain
language models and certified certain
language models as being saved that
anyone and everyone can just constantly
make it wouldn't be it would it make any
sense to even do that because then at
that point
if you certify I don't know spend a lot
of time creating a certifying language
model and I know 10 other people just
create 10 language models without these
certifications without any of the
safeguards and then just deploy them
allow people to use them what is there
to say that someone won't use the kind
of
uncertified model is what what was the
point of making the certified vulnerable
okay this is a very good question and in
this sense I suggest to look into
automobile industry or airplane industry
so you can fly on an airplane without
certification
but it's unlikely it's public Airline or
something but you can
of course so certification is not only
tied to a certain country there are
Universal certifications that any
country can receive that would show the
quality standard so when you use a
language model that is certified that
has standard that was verified and
tested it gives also trust from people
because later I think when people learn
more about this they will also consider
okay this technology is this language
model I hope this will be maybe or not I
don't know what to think about but it
should be also clear and since there are
more Brands so to say of it there will
be also choices and so uh when a
certified people have more trust into it
right or same into automobile industry
you have certification you also have
self-certification that requires uh
actually for the car being produced
there is also how to handle customer
certifications so certification will
never hurt that's for sure I think
because
um
it provides more clearer understanding
of the technology
to the person who provides it Who
develops it and Etc and hopefully to the
users who also may take some lessons or
they may not receive a certificate which
is maybe required for development and
distribution but they can take some
lessons that hopefully will be
introduced to schools and universities
so that's a certification it's just it's
already happening because it is a
technology it should be certified there
should be a standard
can I comment on like I don't think we
can
it's a Fool's earring to try to control
Who develops this or what you're allowed
to develop or what kind of data you can
get what we need to do is regulate use
and uh you have to meet certain
standards in order to use it for certain
purposes we do this all over the place
and you know I can read all I want and
learn all I want about the law but to
practice law I have to be certified uh
in order to engage in that behavior
so I I think this is uh the same thing's
going to happen here we have the same
thing in advert political advertising on
television you know you if you put out
an ad in the the person on whose behalf
the ad is being put as to say I'm so and
so and I approve this ad well that's the
kind of thing we're going to need in a
wide variety of different areas uh you
know probably in education just to pick
something before you're allowed to use
this technology uh on on uh supervised
with respect to say you know 8th graders
uh it has to uh be vetted and meet
certain standards and you'll have
committees that can approve that
um so that that's the way I think this
this whole thing has to be rolled out so
the question is the important question
is can we identify in advance what those
dangers are and lay down those guide
rails in advance or do we need to wait
and see what happens and then try to
roll it back you know you're not allowed
to use this thing to talk to Children
you're not allowed to use it for uh you
know persuading people under certain
conditions or whatever it might be or
for political discourse that's the kind
of restrictions that I think will come
out in regulatory Frameworks over the
next decade or so
I just just ran into an interesting
example that the AI is making Biometrics
less secure
they can record your voice for as little
as five seconds and then completely
reproduce your speech patterns uh visual
you know like face ID uh presumably
could be fooled as these things get
better so it's going to have an impact
on Biometrics which I thought was
interesting
yeah but you know that there are two
there are two levels here we've got the
level where the product is the AI itself
and then it's the product is the
creation of an AI and uh are we going to
give ai's uh agency or not are they
going to be able to sign contracts and
and create things which it then is is
then sold in the marketplace as
belonging to the AI or do you have the
issue of the AI always being a slave to
a human
well Dennis
go ahead
um you know there's major issues in
terms of copyright and patent protection
that hit directly on the kind of issues
that you're talking about you know can
can it be uh protected Can it can the
output of these things be uh copyrighted
uh you know if it comes up with an
invention who owns that these are all
issues that have to be worked out in the
law but you know to me the whole thing
revolves around the legal theory of
product liability you put a product out
there and you say it's good for this and
it turns out it's not good for that or
it's dangerous for that or it has some
side effect you've got liability and I
think that in contrast to what happened
with social media with the you know
section 230 of the uh digital whatever
digital Communications act
um you know we we need to have uh uh be
a lot more restrictive about what kind
of liability goes along with the release
of these particular systems
yeah that's probably true
but I'm not really certain that uh all
of ai's output is going to be a
generated uh under human control uh they
have hallucinations
in some sense they have uh
they could could easily have some sort
of self-generated I must tell a story uh
and continue to tell stories uh built
into the their their internal structure
which we didn't put there they learned
that
and so it's it's not clear at all to me
that we haven't created uh another
source of substantial Intelligence on
the planet and maybe not really clear
intelligence and maybe not all that
smart but it looks to me like it has the
same sort of rights when you can't tell
the difference between the output of an
AI and the output of a human being
it becomes kind of hard to give one
rights than the other not
well but there may be requirements to
label that that's another approach that
this can be but again coming back to the
law of Dennis there's uh there's this
concept in the law about what kind of
control you have over your animals uh
and the interesting thing it's called
first byte Theory and uh really
I'm not making this up
um uh what what happens is you have a
response the question is are you
responsible if your dog bites somebody
and the answer is if you took reasonable
precautions and there was no reason to
believe that that was going to happen
the first time out you don't have a
criminal liability for that if you've
been on if you've been unnoticed and
that's pretty well defined in the law
um then uh then you are liable and there
are people who've gone to jail but the
dogs biting other people because they
had already good evidence that that
might happen and could cause those kinds
of problems so we're going to have to
have some kind of first bite theory for
uh these ai's uh because we just don't
know what they're going to do and they
are kind of like dogs and we just don't
have the leashes yet or we need to
figure out how to get leases and put
them on these systems so that there's
some measure of control uh at least
within some kind of radius or boundary
yeah yeah so I wanted to I like the idea
of the first byte Theory so are you
suggesting you know some company
Facebook open AI releases a a large
language model people discover as they
already have that it can do research
level chemistry and can tell you how to
build
um you know great synthesized nerve
Agents from ingredients you buy at Home
Depot and so somebody does this so the
first time this happens like Facebook
isn't liable uh but the second time they
are and the question is can they even
recall it once the cat is out of the bag
yeah I I I worry about that yeah
yes uh so there is a couple of things I
want to mention so
there was a question regarding uh the
status of a yes or moral and uh
as an agent so for now it is considered
that it doesn't it does not have the
capability to actually be considered uh
as
agent uh or as a heaven personhood so
it's just good to leave space for that
to rethink but currently it is more like
a tool yet there have been propositions
for uh given at the status of electronic
persons so it was a proposition
um like it was different controversial
resolution of 2017 in the European
Parliament so that's um which suggested
that given the most sophisticated
autonomous robot the status of
electronic persons which would be like
one possible legal solution to the issue
of legal responsibility but it was not
taken by European commission into 2018
uh strategy but there is this an idea
that occasionally depending on the
context it may get this electronic
personhood so situational agency
uh because it's already doing things on
its own of course we should also think
how much we want to rely on it because
it all can be hacked it all can go wrong
so uh there is this question as well and
another point was about non-humans
so definitely there's been um
certain Crossing in that sense so how do
we treat on humans and then AI which is
another type of non-human so living on
humans and non-living non-humans
so what the how do we distinguish them
do we value them differently so that's
AI actually equals the dog or is Doc
more valuable or maybe AI more valuable
so I think at the moment probably the
dog is more valuable as a being
but we will see how this goes on
so the first byte theory is actually
um it's it's a good example and it
exists in some sense so some Skeptics
they also consider that there may not be
time for regulations now so it may be
too early because AI is still nascent
right so it would be better to create
rules once a applications appear on the
market and violate existing laws but the
problem is that the violations that may
occur may be quite severe and having
certain chain of consequences
so at least I think it's important to
wrap some head around it or at least try
to so even some regulations on privacy
it already can help to set the limits
how uh the representatives
so yes I think it's all for now so yeah
so how do we approach it do we need
actually to wait something to happen
for example like we discussed uh they're
being security and the other type of
regulations or just system after
9 11 right so the cockpit door was
strengthened the how security Hub do we
need something like this to happen in
technological world to actually start
rethinking the system because it was
like a terrible situation it was a
terrible thing and uh
do we do we need things like that to of
course we can think as a philosophy of
life you know we need to have certain
grotesque things happening to this
experience of life but certain things
do we really need to wait for them
because there are ways to still approach
this we can't do this yeah well we
waited with social media and we found
out it had terrible effects that now
we're having a terrible time undoing so
I don't know if that that holds
yes of course so attention span and kids
for example many having dyslexia now
because of this again competition for
your attention another is different type
of competition going on that also
influence us and even for example such
thing as coronavirus it's not a
technology but still the system of
healthcare
started being were thought deeply to its
roots after such thing happened as a
pandemic when everybody got mocked up at
homes for two years basically when
everybody had to shift to the digital
uh because there were not enough places
or certain system safety
things
[Music]
um
Concepts in place that would help like
washing hands more frequently or wearing
masks in public so like now we know we
have the experience of course it helps
but we all of us going through many
people also died in this process so this
is also something we're looking for yeah
uh to point on on the legal if somebody
just published the graphic novel uh
using a generative AI to do the graphics
and a judge just ruled that she could
copyright the text but not the pictures
yes I saw that I I actually think that
was a bad decision and it was a mistake
because really the question is what's
the human content that's right up till
now it's either been 100 or zero and now
we have something in the middle and uh
again it comes down to curating all of
those uh I I haven't I have an example
about that many years ago I was looking
through a book man and machine and this
was commissioned by IBM when people were
worried about the electronic brain and
they wanted to humanize it and they
brought in stiglitz to go into IBM and
photograph the company's place and one
picture was of one of them was my mentor
when I was a postdoc at IBM and the
picture captured his Essence and I
called them right away and I I said what
was that all about he says oh this guy
came in he shot like a thousand shots
right and he picked that one and it's
the curation that's the copyrightable
aspect not the drawing itself it's
picking the the right one that the
generative AI created
um I had another question about uh the
AI and said something interesting
because my understanding is
that there is no reason for an AI to do
anything
unless someone with a motivation asks it
to do it
um and therefore when the AI does
something bad we have someone to hold
responsible and it's not the AI that did
the bad thing it was the person who
provided the trigger
and I don't think that's true well
um why why this is a this is uh from the
Stephen Pinker book from 20 or 30 years
ago but why would why would his question
was why would a robot choose to do
anything
uh why do we choose to do things he
believes that uh we choose to do things
because of emotion was his answer
um a uh generated AI doesn't have
emotions so why would it do anything
without a prompt
no I don't believe that you can State
the degenerative AI doesn't have
emotions
uh it's uh it may take some new organs
inside of the AI unit to deal with
emotions
uh but then there are lots of things
that require augmentation to be able to
handle things that signals that are not
present in uh in the sequentiality of
symbols yeah certain I'm sitting here
looking at a Chachi PT screen and it
answered my last question but it hasn't
followed up in any way on its own
um is that a just part of the UI or is
that an inherent nature of the system
good question it's a research paper that
you should write I don't know if I'm
competent to answer it
or you can see Disney's The Sorcerer's
Apprentice to see what can happen yeah
but but my point was that that if if the
AI is acting in response to a human
input
then in a sense that human is is
responsible for the output and the AI is
not well I think courts have been saying
that
and the question is is it reasonable is
it a reasonable expectation that you
could have predicted that outcome I
think that comes back to this question
of legal liability that's right yeah so
so it's it's going to be a gray area and
we're going to have an awful lot of
lawyers that are going to be employed
between all of that kind of stuff out
but I'm back on I think on the issue
that you made music when it was first
recorded the Supreme Court decided that
it could not be copyrighted uh and they
that big uproar happened and then that
changed I believe the same thing
happened with photographs that uh you
couldn't you couldn't copyright a
photograph but then uh I think the
example you gave of the curations
photographs change the view that photog
and then photography of course became an
important art form not just simply
something you press a button and record
something so we're going to go through
the same process I think over the next
couple of decades as this as this uh
works out
well I think that you know what
copyright protects against
uh it does not include ideas methods
etc etc etc that's a patent and it has a
whole different set of standards and
rules uh it protects against somebody
making a photocopy that is identical
copy or nearly identical copy that looks
like the original copy and then having a
stack of those books in their
booksellers stand across the street from
the one in that the Publishers of the
actual first copies were and that's the
sort of 15th century publishing uh uh
mechanism the
basically says that copyright protects
the
sense
the sensibility yeah the actual
expression but but Dennis there there
are limitations to that that have been
nuances that have worked out over the
years you've got their use uh you know I
can go ahead and quote you up to a
certain point and I'm not sure what the
rules exactly are on that there is no
rule it's what's ever decided in court
that one I know but
okay so did this uh fair use there's
also um there was something else on that
um oh parody parody You Can Do parody
that's not considered copying
so again it's a judgment that has to be
made but but these are considered uh at
least conceptually exceptions to those
rules yeah
um okay I think to the point that I was
holding the hand right so uh there was a
question about human responsibility
so of course this is a separate question
in this partially because again AI
system is so complicated it consists of
so many elements so there is creation
there is training there is data there is
distribution and Etc and it's only just
a few
that involves different teams of people
so different responsibilities different
actors
that all applies that some make inputs
so there is already issue of
responsibility and when it comes into
the hands of someone
who also do some certain misconduct
there is another question like how this
person is responsible versus technology
so of course currently the human is
responsible because we have moral agency
machine does not have moral agency so we
should be carrying the responsibility
sir we are we just do so it is the way
no it is
but uh the another thing when we have
questions about weaponization of
artificial intelligence it's about like
given you give certain weapon like a gun
to the person who don't know how to use
it or kind of imply misconduct so then
it will be probably a question of
distribution who gave this person this
technology because the conduct was uh
so to be the have a negative
consequences right so then this
allocation of responsibility in general
thinking how do we approach this in this
case so I think when it comes just uh
user versus technology so misconduct of
a user then it comes to the case what
happened because we cannot there is no
Universal model how to judge people if
there would be there would be no court
there will be no judges or any legal
system in place so we have to look what
happened
same with a car crash when car crashes
and there is a driver who is responsible
again we have to look is it caramel
function is it driver wasn't aware maybe
the driver was sick something happened
like I don't know some kind of fainted
during the driving so health issues or
maybe drunk or maybe just a situation on
the road was complicated and no tornado
or some natural issues disasters or okay
turn that a little bit too much but it
was maybe a heavy rain which also
affects the interaction as the road the
friction
so we have to look what's happening
there is no like who is responsible like
one answer for all
so definitely the personalized cases so
maybe there is special
um
certain jurisdiction will be or a group
of
um persons who analyze this if we talk
about legal systems so rights or law on
AI so a certain parts of it or generally
maybe some white except truth because
even in neurological system there are
certain gradings what you can get for
certain misconduct
then generally since it is a technology
I think it will be going to ICT section
so if you misuse social media or also
certain
malicious ends it will be in the
direction I guess
that's really practical though
um most most of these
regulations for behavior
um you say don't use naughty words on
the Internet or
uh even you have to punctuate with
commas and that sort of thing
the rules but we tend to ignore them
people people use
inappropriate words on the internet all
the time they talk about things they
shouldn't we have
um
pictures and stories which are
um not
not polite not acceptable in mixed
company that sort of thing and we we
still muddle along and there there can
be the argument that if you don't have
these bad things in the in the space of
possibility then the good things are not
really identifiable either everything is
always good it's not very interesting I
agree with this disposition if you don't
know the good you can't know the Bad and
the other way but here uh it's more
about like consequence so how the severe
consequences so if somebody says a
couple but words on the Internet or
shares unpleasant story I think it won't
go uh quite a long way but when we talk
about series like terrorism right so
when weaponization of AI when we talk
about many people actually experience
the consequences when it influence
people like manipulating political
campaigns for example that's that's what
I'm talking about in terms of of legal
regulation but this is a daily thing so
somebody can get accused for
this offense in the internet right so
somebody
I don't know had bad conversation with
someone else and I said sure somebody
not it it depends the way it goes I
think so if this proceeds or not what's
the consequences in this even if you
file a suit that doesn't always mean
that you're gonna win or even it will
get reviewed and you can proceed further
to the point so do you think we could
train an AI to be moral
this is a good question but that's a
little different it's a little different
it's um going further so uh we don't
close in the chapter on Allah and going
to morality of where I am because this
is a big question because first of all
can we actually explain our morality can
can we tell how to be moral we don't
know
okay
huh Can you
I can try but I'm not sure I will
succeed because the point is that uh we
act in life we don't think okay I'm
gonna do this because there is this
scripture on morality I'm actually like
I see grandmother uh I want to help her
with products caring for example to the
fourth floor if we're talking about
apartment and then like I have to do
this because Aristotle said it's good
because uh there is other ancient grids
that is good and my mother said that's
good we just act out
not always think this is the problem
this uh computational ethics that or
morality as well so that's you cannot
really always explain what
you're doing
important it's a very important when it
comes to uh structural decisions like
application to the job right so
employment banking you have to explain
but in Daily Life we'll just act
so it's not yes there is some thought
maybe like my mother would think it's
good to help grandmother so I'm going to
do this but generally it's not it
doesn't have this um
kind of strict Sans written so how if we
compute it it still will not act like us
I mean it cannot accept like us but it
will not still get closer yet it doesn't
mean we should give up there are
approaches how to do this so legal
boundaries because legal certain legal
um
Concepts they are also grounded in
ethics and morality
right and they are restated it may be
not it may be clear like don't kill
right we will know this it's bad taking
humans life but it's still in the world
because it happens
so such things stay restated even though
it's kind of Common Sense and that we
can teach through more because law is
more defined it's also easier to explain
because it's in a sense more logically
formed Endeavor can be moral preferences
for example there was an idea for
self-driving cars
to encode a certain sense of morality of
their driver
so what the distance they want to stand
like so of course inter in legal uh
boundaries but you can choose a little
further or a little less so you know
some people are going to stand very
close right into your back and some kind
of further so what type of person are
you in that sense and this kind of
subtle
um things could also give the character
to the this machines so like
self-driving cars it still have human
oversight at least it should
and uh yes so you want you want an AI
which has a conscience
whisper is in your ear oh don't do that
that's a good eye not a good idea this
is uh here we're talking about
um negative ethics and positive ethics
so or just negative ethics for now so
negative ethics is like don't do this
this is prohibited because this is bad
based on here is the least but uh well I
started talking about positive because
it's a vision
of how you want to live how you want to
be so vision of life so it was also in
that video that we should think more
about uh the type of life we want to
reach with this technology or in general
this is positive ethics so how this
technology aligns with the vision of our
future society and what good does it do
okay on morality then unconsciousness
because it's it's a different thing so
it's still considers to be far because
to cause a mind
you need to power so equal or even
higher to the brain
because again we are not just pure
syntax
so
um if it would be syntax then computer
is about the sensor just run in a
program is not enough to create a mind
you can have a imitation or on this
imitation of mind so like we have the
chat Deputy it behaves human-like some
may even fall in love system maybe
because they present this feature so
it's control homorphism I think so that
it presents these features and we
perceive it as human so like this Turing
test idea is
is not really working because Imitation
Of Consciousness doesn't mean there is
consciousness
some people uh think that it does have
Consciousness or emotions it is just a
program running so I don't know what it
would take because it's it's something
that's been started already for many
years and it's generally a mystery of
humankind so there have been this again
from ancient times there have been this
sculptures coming alive I mean in The
Smiths the Golems then Frankenstein so
Recreation of Life what it takes to
recreate the life of course there is
point of Technology like in Frankenstein
electricity got invented so like maybe
electricity can give a life
okay now we have artificial intelligence
maybe this can give a life
maybe it's not so because General the
name artificial intelligence it can be
a little tricky so it was meant as a
study
of a mind through the Practical
incubation of technology so you try to
build the mind or some structures and
you learn more so there are two
directions and we went more into
direction of making useful Smart
Technologies but there is another one
study of consciousness
so
that's on on this
I have a colleague I have a colleague
who's I've talked about this for many
many times and he he is of the opinion
that what we need today to make this
work is a a new religion
and a set of Ethics to fit that religion
you know something like Catholicism at
the uh uh at the point where the church
is split and moved to Constantinople
where there has then a strict code of
conduct and appropriate well there's
some interesting theories about how
strict strict should be uh the uh
there's an interesting paper on
artificial intelligence and
Game Theory which indicates that you
probably want us very strictly enforced
set of rules which has leaks in it that
you can adjust from time to time to uh
to handle the cases that don't get
handled well
but it's it's an interesting thought
that we what we need is a new moral
structure and that moral structure has
to be paired should be parallel to and
tied to how the AIS work and that the
ai's model should be quite good now
there are people who say that uh that's
the that's the prescription for disaster
that was how
um the uh
the folks who wanted to do improve
efficiency by eliminating humans and
have the AIS do all the all of
everything uh was uh probably uh
constructed
um I don't think that's likely to happen
but I suppose that we should should
worry about it
yeah that's a good point I will maybe
start with this enforce morality Falls
so not all people are moral or at least
in our ideas also morality can differ
because Morales is pointed part of it
that it's a little personal can be
cultural but there's still quite
accepted things
same can be this AI enable coming back
to the point of certification there are
widely accepted certificates but of
course people act without them people
buy guns without license people make a
DNA sequencing or in their own Labs or
even before discuss the crispr some do
things on their own they don't need
license they don't need anything they
just need the thing to do
so the materials the technology and
that's it so the results will be some
outliers and there is nothing really you
can do about this because you can't
surveil or you shouldn't be but surreal
everyone just make sure that there is a
circumstander something is not accepted
so the whole public doesn't do this so
people aware of the consequences it was
explained to them and they understand or
at least try to or at least
get some idea because certain it depends
on the How deep the technology is and
then for AI for efficiency like
replacing humans with the eye I also saw
something like that and actually AI can
be or generally algorithmic systems
can be useful to improve efficiency
and reduce bias also human bias because
yes they use small logical data in some
sense like there is a chain especially
when we talk about something like
decision trees
but it still requires human oversight
because it's not always correct and I
think this is part of the certificate
that I talk about is that to actually
teach people how to make decisions with
the schools make a training that it's
not smarter than you like you need to
still look into this like what is going
on you can't just agree with everything
it does so it would be certificate and
like that states like I know how to make
decisions to say iTunes I don't trust it
100 I'm not allocating responsibility on
it just for the sake so I nobody have
questions to me because two decided that
so because this is a problem that people
just think that all it's making
decisions I'm just here accepted them
like I like I already lost my job I
already give up I'm just clicking yes
because it's easier we're wired but
making life easier our bodies were
making life easier and mines we don't
want to do complicated job if there is
an easier way but this is why it's
important to actually understand it's
not as easy job you're not there to
click yes to the algorithm still
oversight is required
well the other thing is if you if you if
you click yes
as a as a regular feature the algorithm
the AI will observe the fact that's what
you do and eliminate that from the tasks
that you have to do because you always
click yes well just your boss will
eliminate for example because like what
what should I do in there you just
clicking yes like but it's it's loses
this idea because
it gets almost on a process
in the process of clicking yes very
forgetting like wait why do we did it in
the first place why this person was
there why it was asking us on whether we
agree or not so this part of the
certification and training that would
help because these systems are not just
developed and kept they're given to
public they're given to Services there
are many AI powered services and those
people they are not developers or
they're not in a company that company
may have some ethical guidelines like
Microsoft Google they have some
but when it shared the third parties
they're not really
so it should come with a certain
training also if you want to use it at
least I very convinced it should
it's like given a car you can buy a car
but you can drive it you have to have a
license to do that you know you need to
know how to behave on a road with other
drivers how to like keep yourself
positioned what to do in certain
situations different things happen
that's what comes with a license and car
or motorcycle or any kind of
driving Transportation airplane airplane
is much stricter so I think in that
sense it's a little closer to AI because
it's more powerful than car
a is more like everything so there can
be AI airplanes AI cars in a sense that
this leveling how how profile how
dangerous the technology not everyone
can drive an airplane or like flight an
airplane in a sense of control in it
which requires a whole school going
through
so
because you give this technology so
teach how to use it I think that's the
basics that should be and I don't really
see it's coming
here unfortunately you don't see you
don't see that there's any alternative
to doing something like that and
utilizing the technology
as if if we choose not to have
regulations what's going to happen
it's very hard to tell
I think regulations is one of the ways
it's already coming so it's already good
because there are some developments in
that area so this is definitely a
benefit because
we already learned that free market
doesn't work so well you can't say
please don't do this they're like okay
we won't
so this is the issue that we have in
right now like please don't make this
very dangerous please don't surveil us
don't take our data uh we feel very bad
it's very dangerous to like
no response continue because competition
gains and Etc so one way to actually
intervene is because government has
power
this just need to help so great from the
field academics we should all come
together users also Express their
concerns what they're afraid of and have
this conversation interdisciplinary
conversation that actually will help to
understand all sides and make the type
of Regulation not just a prohibited this
and then people from their technological
sector they don't know what to do
because
they have no idea how practical is this
how to implement it so this is why
collaboration is important it's not like
government do their thing
it's you don't you don't probably get
all of the US newspapers and read them
like we do here but
um the uh the number of people who uh
have decided how AIS work and how they
uh how they're going to impact things is
really quite large and virtually every
commentator has written a column or two
about it and it's quite interesting what
they they believe AI can do and will do
um it's both uh
much more constrained than it
it is in reality and also Much More Much
broader uh they they work out their
fantasies in in terms of talking about
what the AIS can and can't do
whereas what we have to do is is as
technologists is choose the right the
right thing to do and uh to present that
in a way that's uh ethical and moral in
some fashion without enforcing it
um
um it's it's an interesting and sort of
awesome task which um
probably
the only way to do it is to convince the
AI systems that they should help yeah
yeah in the long run that's right yeah
the the the the other thing that's
interesting is that
there's all this concern about the AI
being a gatherer of
of information building a
a collection of all the world's
information in some fashion and
at least as I understand the process
that doesn't seem to be what what
they're what they're doing what the AI
information gathering thing is the
training is to try to determine the the
symbols that exist in the language of
the system being observed
and their relative frequencies and their
transition probabilities
and the knowledge itself has pretty much
tossed away
and it's very it's very interesting now
how simplistic uh the underlying ideas
really are
yeah uh it's true so this is the
generally question of this uh algorithms
and models because models are just
simplification of life it does not
represent life and some people believe
in AI that it's actually like I don't
know
that it will this AGI concept so strong
intelligence artificial intelligence and
generally that's this kind of ideas on
its
you know human-like intelligence is that
they think human intelligence is just a
syntax so simplified so but it doesn't
take all the complexity because another
thing that exists
in not even Academia but the the
simplest answer is like the most correct
so it's the right one but Occam's razor
huh it's cool
I just forgot Costco so like is it
really so
um
I doubt it to be honest so because I
don't think the simplest answer is
always the best so simplest answers
they might be a more appealing
that's for sure but
because it's hard to get onto complexes
and wrap your hands or head around it
depending on different issues not only
AI
so indeed so reduce the knowledge to
symbols and language reducing human
consciousness and intelligence to syntax
just some program in our head running
I don't know
I think it doesn't take this is where
the issues come from
generally so this is the human element
in all this that reflected in technology
that we should think as a part of ethics
well there are people who've argued that
uh building a uh uh a
artificial intelligence General
degenerative artificial intelligence
agent
I could be done where it had emotions
and it responded emotionally as well as
uh intellectually or the next symbol
could change the mood of the statement
and some of that sort of thing so it
increases the the fan out of of options
and makes the decision-making process
much more difficult but it also makes it
much richer
and
um there's a a guy at Stanford who's
been working on that sort of change he
has it's different it's different it's a
different slightly different approach
than the neural net
but it's a sort of a hypergeometric net
and it's
it's always appealed to me and there are
people working on uh building hardware
for it
and it would be a possible possibility
and you know their their interest has
always been to try to create something
that's obviously conscious in some
fashion
and maybe this
this round of artificial intelligence
machines are uh sort of brain dead at
some level there's certainly not
emotionally
capable but they're they could hint what
really could be done elsewhere in the
next round of machines will look much
their models will look much more
interesting and complicated
um and maybe that's what everybody's
worried about maybe that's what why
everybody says well no more
no more stuff with neon gpt4 until such
time as we understand more
yeah
I don't know
anyhow I'm going to have to go now
myself
so thank you very much it's always
a great pleasure to have you um talking
and I think uh I think that uh
I think that your your ideas are
well I mean there are several of us here
who think you're uh uh your colleague is
not a uh a person out on the map so we
we very very pleased to have you around